o no abbiamo letto che c'è un limite
tutti bentornati 33
ciao lawzi nuovo editore di shopping
bendata però questa volta dalla lista
desideri almeno siamo sicuri che prendo
qualcosa che sicuramente non è vero non
mi dicono neanche bene cosa fosse
realizzata sideri comunque si sarà un
massimo di articoli attivo cinque
articoli dalla mia vita desideri
speriamo di prendere le cose che vi
servono di più di più non solo prendere
le cose dalla lista desideri ma vi
regalerò anche qualcosa cioè vado a fare
un giveaway e vi dico subito che cosa vi
regalo è come partecipare come vi regalo
numero uno vi regala uno slide kit da 61
pacchetti tra cui berline di acqua
marina carta da zucchero griglia occhi
finti guscio fede confetti perlini
schiuma di melbourne hanno usato come un
translate imitazione fogliano per me ma
che fa mestiere fai da te contenere lo
slime ora me almagro mestiere
quindi vi regala questo kit che è anche
quello che ho preso io poi alla fine in
questo video vi lascio il link in cui
faccio la boxing di questo kit così
potete vedere meglio cosa c'è dentro
peluche di shane mai astuccio un ricordo
ed è bellissimo e uno struzzo nico a
forma di bush in tutto il contrario
e poi cena forma di ritorno per la sua
forma di un ricordo le di cuscini è un
astuccio di cucina ma senza ma e questo
che cani che bellino in più ci sarà ora
mi sembrano dar oggi da attimo della
vendita
[Musica]
come si chiama perché siamo che possiamo
che ci sarà un'altra sorpresa che
scegliero io quindi non vi dico cosa e
quale non è una sorpresa
io non lo dico per la sorpresa per
partecipare dovete essere iscritti al
canale attivare la campane limina quindi
affinare le notifiche poi dovete
seguirmi su internet e in nome anni
testori
lasciate un commento nessuno veloce
facebook dove mettere mi piace anche la
mia pagina facebook che si chiama aiuto
per niente dovete detto ma essere attivi
sul canale guardare i miei video la
sarei like sui miei video la sera online
su questo video lasciate un commento
socio questo video scrivendo che avete
partecipato che vi servite su internet
il vostro nickname su integra anche e
poi andrò a leggere un vincitore fra due
settimane quindi in descrizione di mezzo
esattamente il giorno qui e leggerò il
vincitore è vincitore apparirà nella
descrizione di questo video fra due
settimane quindi ricordatevi di
riguardare la descrizione di questo
video
sarà qualche poi dovrà insomma
contattando un mercato prima altri
problemi a no per adesso quindi dalla
mia lista di desiderio di riprendere il
contenuto di bella di utile e poi
andremo a fare la boxing perché faremo
un viaggio nel tempo e le boccia saranno
già fatte fare con la bocca di una
schietta e io non saprò cosa ho scelto
finanza nei due bracciali cabal e quindi
sarà come un mistery box
però così e di questa cosa vide
raggiungere 200 mila be used 200.000
visualizzazioni andrò farne un altro in
cui farò un altro che ma wayne farò
altro shopping dalla mia lista desideri
quindi condividetela con i battenti
facciamolo raggiungere i 200.000 viaggi
e ora iniziamo subito sono su amazon può
imitare cliccherà nella mia lista
desideri spero non sia niente di
imbarazzante non esiste comunque massimo
cinque articoli speriamo di prendere le
cose che mi servono di più altre cose
che mi corre cosa sono
non è orami bello e iniziamo ok fai qui
no brava sicura l'intera dell'acqua a
richiamo sulla discrimine
[Applauso]
ok fatto certo sì credo sia questa no no
no stop
ok allora dov'è ma se per il primo
articolo
clicco se stai fuori dal sun dà uno
schiaffo vero
chicco hpv per avere il bottone aggiunge
il carrello no io prometto troppo i tool
agenzia carrello veloci ormai altri
genoma clima tomba si deve premere solo
dall'articolo ha aggiunto di racconta
carrello proprio sullo spigolo a circa
raduno al cavallino
ok arnaldo ok siamo di nuovo l'analista
si senza in paradiso
diamo sto scendendo piano piano si sta
scendendo di vista e scendendo solo
periodo anche risate si fuori dalla
nessuno sulla barra
il secondo articolo
[Musica]
non posso prenderla due volte si è
cliccato su un articolo online
volevo giunto il capello è ficcato si ok
adesso ha cliccato la werth ok che
dobbiamo però togliere l'indirizzo ok
terzo articolo risaniamo un po
[Applauso]
[Musica]
qua e selezionato regala questo articolo
a quell altro articolo che avevi questo
prima facciamo la spunterà calo comunque
un regalo da vita anche applicato falco
lanza ed un articolo
ok di continua siamo già al terzo si
evita che era scappato dai 73 sistema
offerto facendo quello che in fretta
cento così stai alla cittadella della
pace per la cinquina finale donde stai
fuori dalla tua lista
ok adesso stai sulla lista ok
[Musica]
questa applicano qualcosa che stai prova
al limite della pagina applicato per
guardare allora lo aggiungo che speriamo
che siano cose tutte che voglio ancora
non state vecchie questo è carino non ho
aggiunto aggiunge a carlo ok adesso
l'abbiamo aggiunto ho dovuto si era
bloccata la vagina dovuto ricaricarla ok
come ricontrollare dobbiamo finirla non
è però uno ancora un occhio per cazzo
spendendo troppo ora 1 sono nella pagina
sigle ok non si sta muovendo adesso
seguo aiuto storia di prendermi una vera
mente che ti serve tanto spero di
prendermi
il ruolo come ultimo facendo questo è
stato cliccato quanto andarsene perché
che cos'è previsto il 20 di strano non
ero dico una fornitura di carta igienica
per tre anni perché strana parte
dell'imbarazzante no a fare l'ordine
completare l'ordine e poi una volta che
l'aifa noi abbiamo
[Musica]
perché mi devo aprire io perché la roma
ciao sono arrivati tutti i falchi
finalmente iniziamo il nostro unboxing
sono troppo curioso troppo curioso e
proprio pacchetto other man the mask
freedom mascari via calmate e idratante
ricordo questa era è una maschera brevi
tutte velocemente che avevo messo perché
voglio fare appunto delle maschere la
notte quindi mi spaventerebbe notte le
mascherate fantasma trasparente il più
grande lo stiamo lasciando lo stesso
pesa un po questo pensa di meno quello
che pesa di me
[Musica]
mamma mia mi fermo qua c'è una crema per
il corpo
questo lavoreremo da un sacco ed altre
verde e al nettare di miele comunque era
chiamato il corpo che dico che sia
fantastica che morbidi scadentissimo la
pelle o vicino casa
non lo so ma la scatolina e un po
sospetta è stata ok io non ho scelto io
lo hai scelto tu ad occhi chiusi
oh mio dio paura di vedere cosa c'è qua
detto poco sesso cercando di ricordare
cos'è un mezzo di costoso nella lista
desideri dire che era qualcosa che ti
piaceva bing rizzato che però ha detto
che c'era un limite di budget
con il limite siamo quindi non sono
diamanti diamanti vero ti amo tanto non
mi ricordo però devo dire di essere
avermi limiti e immagino che ti
piacevano ti ho lasciato a comprarle
e poi scusate la benda ormai guardate
questi corsi sono giganteschi bellini
che sono cosa spiega così tanto amati
segno di plastica nel un emettitore
ottenere così come c'è scritto non
avevano al prezzo non avevano il prezzo
di diamanti per immagini agi
e importante che siamo stati dentro il
basso budget dopo benefico quanto sono
costati questi sono bellissimi comunale
di tutto ti preoccupavi ora cappelli
insomma se non li mentre non veri e
quello che mi preoccupa affatto mia se
qui che siamo stati capaci di aiuto
chiamato alberi o strade dal budget un
mio zio mi è venuto un infarto veramente
perché cominciamo a togliere le forbici
non è una pubblicità re una pubblicità a
niente che hanno messo degli orecchini
ma mi ricordo non non fatti così mi
dicono quelli tondi che però non
volevano c'erano anche molto anche
avremo il prossimo comunque finale sono
felicissimo ovviamente perché nella mia
lista desideri normali desideri di anni
pastori poi sistema urbano di contattato
da qualche anno le orecchie questore
c'era altro
in orecchini smalto marocco cosa corallo
poi se portava dentro ad un picco di
aver messo queste cose
se desideri comunque penso forse per il
mondo lo smalto poi un foglietto un
altro smartphone
questo è un color viola scuro bellissimo
a un capitano destro ma perché mi dicono
panico ieri quindi queste tutti si sono
rifatti in gel primiero aperto proprio
pacchetto nonna perché i fatti e nero
[Musica]
sarà aperta contro la studenti ceramista
insieme un po nostri controlli invitate
non mi è mai successa una cosa del
genere che aprissero il pacco
controllassero sono proprio i controlli
parliamo
vediamo se c'è tutto entro queste devono
essere 345 vediamo qualche monrosa bello
scrivetemi di che colore fare del mio
colore mi devo fare l'inviata questo e
colori nel suo metodo qua poi un altro
che bello bellissimo viola fucsia si
siano bello che c'è neppure un altro e
questo è un color sabbia di carne di che
colore faccio le unghie la prossima
volta
questa mattina hai detto che ti piace
arrosto sì ma questo ritengo più che si
rimanga comporta agosto
segno dello sfavore sono presissimo
ovviamente tutti i potenti idea se
l'ultimo insomma la tappa del processo
di una costa 45 una cosa sola
ma mi stavo divertendo un amore così
grande che c'era una cosa che decisero
che era il l'epilatore all'alter ma
quello che penso proprio che siate
quello di grande e adesso lo scopre così
il massaggio schiena in realtà non è
stato schiacciato fondo anche per i
piedi mi sta scritto collo e spalle
mi sparano schiera con questo porta
vediamo come stanno troppo rivolta
questo adattatore
oddio peta ha pure non portare in
macchina aspetta accaduto ma pregiato
col batterista via verso l'esterno
hanno una batteria sì sì ci vediamo un
po che strano che io con le spalle con
lo schienale vita addome cosce o atti
benissimo tipo di le palline quando a
questo perché negarlo anche il materiale
quando messico una punta un po però
quindi non si assegna nostri pezzo che
sia addio da subito paura
vediamo emesso ben hassine poi li sulla
destra
e allora vedi così devi inserire nel
manico dentro quindi non posso tenere il
computer c'è una decisione muro merco
non è un montagne e robusta lo può
tenere anche solo sul collo anche solo
un collo e se la farina un ritmo schiano
sullo schema allora così più basso
sembrava e poi mi sei bottoni
la funzione arriva gravissimo se scende
sia acceso tutto di rosso si scalda pure
è prospettata detto oddio è una trans
perché stiamo lamentavano delle mani che
fa ma contro se un po troppo forte
aspetto possa andare con la l'intensità
senso di rotazione dei massari siamo
nella vita è una serie di questo tipo
ap di meno
metti un meno possibile a siri nostante
la schiera poi su quello permettere
anche prima del collo ok troviamo
l'accordo che mentre capelli fantastico
[Musica]
abbiamo il vento forte però come un
affarone
sono dedicati appunto tant'è che abbiamo
ci si dovrebbe forse ne bisogna
controllare l'aurora tutto bello forte
ma sembra dei pugni che fanno molto
maschia ma però prescritto maschio nato
male mattina un pochino più delicato
massaggio però se sono tipo tanti
cerchietti che girano fanno consigli
sulla schiena quindi è un po forte ok
ragazzi non vi preoccupate non sono
povera non moriremo di fame non sono
veri diamanti al se alla fine non
costavano tanto per essere fatti così
bene e me li posso provare quindi
vediamo come mi stanno speriamo che non
si rompa il primo giorno ti formerà
infatti inquadra lo sapeva beh così
contento quando direzionato verso detto
se finalmente mano a mano che mi è
toccato poi nera di questo vi ho detto
che cos'è questa volta questo mio parere
contenta non abbiamo capito che cos'è la
loro foto ma lo immaginavo rete nei
propri numeri
i comuni stanno buche belli si guarda
aperto
ditemi voi con vista come mi stanno
scrivetevi dei commenti ben altro pensi
ma perché fare subito la propria lista
desideri da me si può provare a fare un
massaggio in testa del progetto giorno
se magari stimolo il signor bello giusto
per se vorreste vedere un altro video
simile fa servizio presenta nei commenti
ditemi cosa ne pensate di più tra tutte
queste cose che a mio padre poche ore e
orecchini la crema una colpa da dove la
maschera per il viso e mathis ma tutti
colorati quali sono i vostri colori
preventivi l'italia infatti seri in
questi giorni e quindi sui motivi nei
commenti cosa mi è piaciuto di più se vi
siete divertiti e ora vi lasciamo un
papà forecasters conficcare volete
vedere altro shopping se volete vedere
le nostre challenge video divertenti
indicare su quello che preferite e buona
visione
ciao ciao